[Música]
habitabilidad buscar una palabra para
describir nos como consumidores
pospandemia wow es todo un reto el 6 de
marzo del 2020 volvía de un viaje de
trabajo de costa rica a guatemala
viendo creo que como muchos de nosotros
con algo de incredulidad lo que empezaba
a suceder empezamos a vivir en marzo
2020 lo que
ninguno de nuestros sueños podríamos
haber imaginado nuestras vidas cambiaron
tanto en lo laboral en lo social y por
supuesto como compradores el que no haya
tenido algún cambio en el último año es
un extraterrestre o alguien en otra
dimensión para los que nos gustan las
tramas como aquella de volver al futuro
porque a todos los demás si tuvimos que
adaptarnos a las circunstancias de un
solo golpe sin previo aviso y sin mucho
tiempo para asimilarlo
yo mismo recuerdo una conversación que
tuve con un médico amigo que por allí
por el mes de febrero del año pasado
comentábamos lo que pasaba en asia y me
decía que lo más probable es que aquí no
llegaría ni pasaría nada al inicio de la
pandemia sin embargo si pasó entonces
nos adaptamos a las largas filas para
entrar a los diferentes establecimientos
comerciales también a las aglomeraciones
para comprar los famosos limpiadores en
aerosol qué tal si comparamos el aroma a
pan caliente y las filas que hacíamos en
nuestros barrios para comprar este pan
pues ahora el aroma que nos atraía era
el de desinfectante y el limpiador
literalmente se iba como pan caliente a
las personas salían pues los carritos
zulia dos de alimentos productos para
limpieza
y si repletos de papel higiénico y es
que más de una vez recibí la pregunta de
por qué hubo el boom de papel higiénico
pues bueno muchas hipótesis hay estoy
segura que todos leímos y recibimos más
de alguna broma en la pandemia en
relación a este tema nos comportamos
como un rebaño hacíamos lo que otros
hacían pero eso sí nos adaptamos a los
protocolos sanitarios al uso de
mascarillas al distanciamiento e
inclusive nos adaptamos a las
restricciones vehiculares nos volvimos
expertos numéricos para poder tener
claro qué día de la semana podíamos
circular o no en otros países también se
adaptaron a otro tipo de restricciones
por ejemplo en panamá podían salir a
hacer sus compras un día hombre es otro
día mujeres y si nos confundimos de día
limón guau verdad que qué enredo este
junto con este tipo de restricciones que
hubo no sólo en costa rica en panamá en
guatemala o en otros países de
centroamérica también alrededor del
mundo nos adaptamos a nuevos hábitos y
formas de comprar empezamos a gastar
mucho más en productos de consumo masivo
principalmente en alimentos
abarrotes productos de limpieza para el
hogar productos sanitarios por mencionar
algunos en costa rica por ejemplo en los
dos primeros meses de inicio de la
pandemia es decir por allá por marzo y
abril gastamos en productos de la
canasta a un 8 por ciento más de dinero
versus los mismos meses del año 2019 un
comportamiento de compra pues
completamente atípico al que en otros
años hemos podido evidenciar al estar
más en casa nos adaptamos a nuevas
rutinas y actividades dentro de ella se
vieron afectadas categorías sectores de
la canasta de consumo masivo que están
más ligadas a interacciones u ocasiones
fuera del hogar más ligadas a la
socialización como maquillajes o
fragancias presentaron bajas
significativas en sus ventas yo pues
bueno no sé ustedes pero puedo dar fe
que durante este tiempo en casa en mi
rutina de maquillaje ya no fue la misma
y ahorre maquillaje y por qué no decirlo
quizás perfume también finalmente en la
videollamada aún no hay olores mientras
que otras categorías o sectores
relacionados a la higiene diaria allí sí
otras nuevas necesidades de limpieza y
alimentación es así crecieron durante el
confinamiento
la frecuencia en la que realizamos las
compras disminuyó drásticamente en costa
rica se pasó de comprar 133 veces a 114
lo que significa una disminución del 14
por ciento de la frecuencia con la que
vamos a comprar a un lugar pero esto nos
llevó a gastar 8 % más cada vez que
comprábamos impulsados sobre todo por
compras de abastecimiento adaptándonos a
las circunstancias también cambiamos
nuestro perfil de compras nos volvimos
compradores más decididos
experimentadores más apurados también
porque no queríamos pasar tanto tiempo
en un establecimiento y esto es parte de
lo que podemos hoy quedarnos como
consumidores pospandemia vamos más
directamente a lo que queremos pero
también estamos abiertos a la
experimentación con lo que nos atraen
innovaciones que el mercado nos presenta
nos adaptamos a nuevas formas de comprar
como las compras también por medio de
teléfono las aplicaciones las páginas de
internet o inclusive el whatsapp no
aunque tenga a veces allí sus sus
temitas aunque en el pasado posiblemente
ya usábamos este tipo de plataformas
para comprar tecnología moda u otros
tipos de productos la novedad fue
empezar a comprar productos de canasta
como alimentos bebidas productos de
cuidado personal por estos medios lo que
se esperaba crecer para 2025 fue el
crecimiento que se tuvo en 5 meses de
pandemia ya hoy 31 por ciento de hogares
en centroamérica compran la canasta de
consumo masivo por comercio electrónico
muchos nos preguntamos bueno
es que todo esto pase cómo va a ser el
nuevo normal que nos espera pues ojalá y
tuviéramos aquella famosa bolita de
cristal para conocer qué va a pasar con
este mundo
quizás post comida cuando finalmente
digamos chau pandemia y volvamos a la
normalidad no estoy tan segura de
llamarle así lastimosamente tenemos pues
mucho todavía por aprender no podemos
predecir el futuro pero sí podemos saber
que a ciencia cierta somos hoy
compradores mucho más analíticos que
decidimos mucho más racionalmente porque
también el presupuesto world by así no
es importante
ilimitado puedo confirmar que lo digital
llegó para quedarse
regresaremos si a comprar menos para el
hogar porque otra vez vamos a salir con
más regularidad y el entretenimiento
otra vez más fuera que dentro de casa
pero nuevas rutinas esas se van a quedar
limpieza como algo básico de nuestro día
a día nuestras compras lo reflejan
comida que nos haga sentir también
especiales a nosotros ya nuestras
familias
alimentos que aporten salud y bienestar
también van a seguir pues hay un
contexto clave de relevancia de la salud
y también que la ecosostenibilidad se ha
vuelto importante las innovaciones para
nosotros los consumidores siguen siendo
también una clave porque queremos probar
productos novedosos que satisfagan
nuestras nuevas necesidades
pero más allá de saber qué va a pasar es
saber que ante situaciones inesperadas
como las que hemos vivido
capaces de adaptarnos
fabricantes marcas industria adaptemos
también de manera más ágil la oferta a
las necesidades que como consumidores
estamos demandando la adaptabilidad debe
venir de todos los lados realmente los
consumidores nos adaptamos pero
esperamos lo mismo de todas las partes
adaptabilidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]